in the craft achievement categories we
begin with animator motion graphic
designer with the Emmy going to Lance
Eckert motion graphics designer splash
media all that's extra I'm going to know
what you think so please give us your
reviews and comments here's how
thank you thank you so much thank you
thank you um it's a real honor to be
standing in front of you right now I
never really thought this would happen
this award I just didn't think that then
it was possible that I could with it I
just had no idea I'm so emotional and
happy and just be so grateful and a lot
of adjectives right now and I just don't
know how to describe it but it's gonna
thank everyone there's actually some
people that I'd like to thank and since
I'm I'm so unprepared I have a white
board of some people I'd like to think
extra and /media just for being awesome
I'd also like to thank my mom and my dad
and rip effort um Steve Jobs nachos cuz
you're like so tasty like a little treat
my space please for grabs
um flair for you're always so
inspirational music Walmart because
you've always got those everyday little
prices every day every day that's what
you do
um USB and firewire for always being
there for me to plug things in to
Britney Spears and Billy jewel I didn't
write that there's somebody somebody
hijacked my Expo marker I didn't write
these things um I don't I don't know I
thought that was a good idea of what
letters are rubbing off it's just an
expo marker and a white board okay well
thank you thank you
anymore like dinner there's food here
such type of snacks